Good day everyone.
This is Paul and you are watching the
langue focus Janel and today we're going
to talk about that some interesting
stuff.
We're going to talk about the difference
between a language and a dialect.
Now,
what is the difference all over the
world there are people who speak closely
related forms of communication.
Sometimes they are called different
languages.
Sometimes they are called dialects of
one language,
so how do we decide which one they are?
Sometimes there's some disagreement
about which one a particular form of
communication is.
Is it a dialect or is it a separate
language?
The dialect really means in a variety of
speech that differs somewhat from
another variety of speech of that same
language.
It could differ in grammar,
it could differ in phonology or
pronunciation.
It could.
Different vocabulary could different.
All of those may be,
sometimes those dialects are based in
different regions.
They are regional varieties of a
language.
Sometimes they are ethnic varieties of a
For example,
maybe there are two ethnic groups living
in a city,
but historically they've lived separate
and not really interacted with each
other because of racism or whatever.
And they've developed a separate dialect
because of that separation.
So they're almost living in two worlds
within the same city,
that kind of thing.
So it's almost like a different regional
dialect inside your your on talent if
you know what I'm in now,
within every language there is some
degree of variety,
some degree of difference.
There are some different spoken
varieties of every language.
So how do we decide if it's close enough
to the language to be considered a
dialect and when is it not?
Well,
one of the men criteria that is most
often used is mutual intelligibility.
That means the speakers of those two
different varieties of the language can
understand each other fully or almost
fully understand each other.
We would say they're mutually
intelligible in that case.
So according to this definition,
simply if you can understand each other,
you can understand them and you can make
yourself understood to them,
then you are speaking the same language.
And if even if there's some degree of
difference in grammar or phonology or
vocabulary,
those are just dialectal differences
because you can understand each other.
The languages are close enough that they
are considered the same language
according to that definition.
Now the problem with this definition is
that sometimes speakers of what is
considered to be one language often
can't understand each other.
Like for example,
often I can't understand people who
speak a Scottish dialect of English.
When I say it to somebody else,
I'll tell you about you finally got the
boys.
Often,
I can't understand people who speak a
Scottish dialect of English or sometimes
an Australian dialect of English.
If they come from like the deep
countryside of Australia,
sometimes I can't them.
And this is especially true if I
overhear two of those people speaking
together,
I hear them speaking with each other and
not directly to me.
Then they'll speak in their full on
different accent,
different dialect,
and sometimes I can't understand.
So are we speaking a different language
because it's not mutually intelligible.
So that's kind of the difficult point of
this definition.
Sometimes I can't understand other
speakers of English,
but I think it's the same language.
And so do they.
So what's going on there?
So that brings me to another criteria of
what would make to spoken varieties just
to dialects of one language and that is
this.
Both of those varieties used the same
written standard variety of language.
These are the same written standard,
the same written language.
Even though the spoken language means
differ somewhat so that would explain
why I speak English and a Scottish
person speaks English even if there may
be some trouble communicating.
We both use the same written language.
You both rate in the same way.
We read the same books and then when we
speak to each other we can adapt our
speech to make it a little bit more like
the written standard.
Now that's why we can communicate even
though I can't really understand their
variety of English when they speak the
pure form,
when they speak it with each other,
I don't,
I don't really know what they're saying
a lot of the time,
but when they speak to me they kind of
use a book English a little bit literary
English.
They use more of the written standard
and mix it in with their natural dialect
to make it understandable to me.
And I think I do the same unconsciously.
So that's what makes us speakers of the
same language.
The fact that we,
we blend our variety of speech with that
Sam written standard and that's what
helps us to communicate across day
Alexa.
Now the one weakness in this criteria
and is that there are people who can't
really speak to the standard language
that well.
So that's true in English.
You have some people who are uneducated
and maybe they're poor,
maybe high school dropouts,
maybe they're the type of people who
just don't really care about studying or
speaking properly.
They don't really know the standard
language.
They might understand it,
but they can't speak like that.
So are those speakers have the same
language even though they don't really
know how to use the standard written
language properly.
So that's kind of the trouble with,
with that criterion.
But so far that's the best criteria that
I've found to explain what is a dialect
and what's a language that written
common standard language.
Now as with all things in life,
the situation gets just messy when we
bring politics into it,
because sometimes we have a,
we have two varieties of language that
are almost exactly the same,
but they have two different names in two
different countries or their spoken by
two different ethnic groups and they
both clem that language as their own.
So they call it by different names and
it causes a lot of weird confusion.
So I've,
I think it's like that in the former
Yugoslavia for some of the languages
there,
there are people who just don't want to
be associated with the other people.
So they,
they called the language by the name of
their own ethnic group,
even though it's the Sam as the language
of another ethnic group basically.
So even though the standard written
language might be pretty much the Sam
might be slightly different,
but it's pretty much the,
and the spoken language is pretty much
the same.
Maybe with some variation,
but they're mutually intelligible.
Even the standard written languages
mutually intelligible,
but they call it a different language
because of whack ass politics.
I don't like politics.
I'm not a political person.
I'm more interested in cultures and in
people,
so I don't really buy that definition.
I don't like it when people say we speak
a different language because we have a
different ethnic group at different
nationality.
We're going to call this language hours.
It's not yours,
it's ours.
I don't really like that kind of
territorial claiming of languages so I
don't buy this definition.
I think if you can speak together with
each other and it's mutually
intelligible,
you can read the same books.
Then in my opinion you're speaking the
same language.
I don't really buy the political
definition of what's the language and
what's a dialect.
So basically my definition of a dialect
is that it's mutually comprehensible
with another variety of language.
So if you can communicate with them,
they understand you,
you understand them,
and you can use the written language
elements of the written language to make
yourself even more understood.
Then I think you were speaking dialects
of the same language.
I hope that is helpful.
I hope that gives you some something to
think about.
Leave your comments down below.
Tell me if you agree with my opinion on
this matter.
All right,
this is Paul signing off.